je suis pas dans le jeu suit pas le plus
chaud que j'ai été à depuis le début du
confinement j'ai envie de dire mais on
va quand même soit une petite arena en
trois échecs mais je vous promets pas je
crains pas les commentaires les plus
enflammés de ma vie un bond de four le
parce que papa ce qui est un peu de un
peu de fatigue à la forcément non je
sais pas si c'est live ou pas je vais à
l'échec et ça c'est pas ici c'est ici
et ouais ça a l'air d'être live donc
c'est bon ça vient de démarrer et il ya
cet échec déjà qui est dans le dans le
chat à l'usta chèques alors les biens et
non non et bien on est bien on y vient
soit meilleur truc
ouais je suis bien je suis bien sûr la
bonne chaîne chasse com/fr cette fois ci
salue joris salut au grand maître gims
ça lui fait de beaux rêves
salut les amis et la conquête de ce we
can't wait je te cache pas se cacher que
sam à sa mamie ça m'a mis un peu dans la
dans la fatigue je te le cache pas mais
on viendra on reviendra là dessus on
reviendra là dessus je pense ce soir
quand on fera les petites parties avec
fab
j'en reparlerai peut-être on en
reparlera sûrement sûrement on
rediscutera un peu de ça
là du coup à
là du coup c'est vrai que le lundi midi
et tout un jeu pas forcément fin je suis
naturel quoi comme toujours
oui mais mais bon forcément il ya un peu
de fatigue à la forcément et salua
ghislaine donc aujourd'hui va se faire
un teint mat de trois échecs pour tenter
je me suis dit comme on est peut-être un
peu tout seul claqué je vais jouer je
vais y participer aussi on va voir ce
que ça donne c'est longtemps que tu vas
jouer trois échecs
je me suis dit que c'était une bonne
idée de de récupérer de cette manière et
d'essayer quelque chose finalement un
petit peu quelque chose mais j'ai mis 60
minutes parce que parce que plus ça va
être dur en fait le but du jeu c'est de
faire trois échecs du coup 1 2 3 et et
vous gagnez et merci à joris pour
l'abonnement de niveau 1 merci tonton
salut amar khune tier premier salaire
ferait de gama russe à l'ue a maugréé
salut à marfa briki merci pour pour hier
ouais je sais tellement stressant on ne
fait rien complètement on en reparlera
on en reparlera ce soir jamais je
travaille et va être difficile ouais
c'est un jeu difficile moi non plus je
suis pas très bon mais voilà ce pour
essayer quelque chose faire attention de
pas se prendre des chèques en fait aux
trois échecs
c'est ça le truc
c'est ça la difficulté c'est pas trop se
prendre des chèques rapidement et salue
french petrosyan retraite on tue pas
vraiment de faire spoiler ferait de gama
rue il n'y a pas grand-chose à spoy
l'envoi et le math compte pour 3 as tu
fais maths tu gagnes aussi s'attacher
avec mes torts a fait trois échecs avant
c'est très rare de faire maths parce que
normalement tu vas un peu attiré le roi
adverse et tu vas faire quelque chose
quoi ces trucs quoi les 3 et jacques
d'en tuer trois échecs dans la partie et
a gagné au troisième échec tu as gagné
en fait donc c'est pour ça que ça va
rarement au match ça plus souvent au
troisième échec quoi même si matt gagne
la partie en soi quelle stratégie joué
une fois dans ma vie mais en gros
essayent de cacher 3 quoi pas se prendre
des chèques
on va dire ça la strate se prendre un
échec et problématiques genre admettons
tu fais c'est pas mêmes scandinaves tu
vois c'est injouable parce que échec
échec
admettons çà et là les blancs ont un
énorme avantage parce qu'il manque un
échec pour gagner la partie
donc en gros le même jour un truc comme
dan f3 tu me fais un échec je le couvre
et là je me nadège adam price est et
dames français 6
c'était déjà fini en fait parce que si
tu bouges leroy sur la colonne des jeux
fait échec
et sinon tu peux pas empêcher et dames
preuve cette aidé à me prend ses 6 ok ce
truc faire d'un coup deux échecs et
c'est vrai que je peux pas faire croire
qu eux deux ce que tu fais qui est des
cas troisième échec
donc je serai obligé de bedat francs
maçons là je menace échec et j'ai quand
même une dame de plus
donc ça freine d'être cool pour les
blancs
mais du coup du coup c'est un jeu quand
même intéressant c'est une variante
plutôt intéressante
ça change un peu moins j'avais bien aimé
la fois j'avais joué j'avais trouvé ça
intéressant élevé des combinaisons
tactiques un peu différente de
d'habitude et c'était assez cool en tout
cas ça a le mérite de changer un petit
peu il y aura des arnaques de fou
l'uniforme qui est fait mais possible
c'est plus la même façon de calculer du
coup c'est plus la même façon de
calculer c'est un jeu différent et du
coup c'est sympa quoi mais ça garde
quand même un peu des trucs d'échec de
base il faut vraiment en avoir accès un
échiquier d' analyse non je sais pas ça
guillaume a peut-être mais c'est
tellement longtemps que j'ai de diamants
que je me rappelle plus pointues de
conduire répertoire d'ouvertures rsa
sera fait wake corn flakes avec des
choses assez simples avec des choses
assez simpliste lorsque l'on parle du
répertoire gratuit sur youtube avec des
vidéos qui dépasseront pas 30 minutes
par ouverture et des choses probablement
beaucoup plus compliqué lorsqu'on
passera sur assure du c'ur du payant
dans un deuxième temps mais pour
s'assurer que le confinement se termine
et c'est donc c'est pas demain la veille
on en saura plus ce soir peut-être déjà
avec l'intervention de notre cher
président à 20h02
et moi je partirai live après coup la
vidéo de ce matin viseur ngage
intéressante en tout cas ça permet de
devoir de voir de nouveaux concepts de
nouvelles choses c'était une partie
intéressante et demain du coup il y aura
là bitstream cap en redif et mercredi je
mettrai en rediffusion l'interview de
hennezel du coup du coup voilà un peu un
peu ce qui attend sur la chaîne youtube
et puis par la suite j'avais déjà filmé
avant de confinement une partie vraiment
sympa qui était cramique shirov une des
plus belles parties d'attac que j'ai vu
de ma vie ça ce sera sympa et eux et
après il y aura du répertoire facile il
ya d'autres choses qui vont sortir
à vrai dire il est plus ou moins prévu
de faire des vidéos tous les jours
jusqu'à dimanche prochain à lundi je
sais pas quand je vais m'arrêter je ne
sais pas quand je vais m'arrêter
en fait en gros ça va je vais récupérer
jusqu'à faut que je récupère de la
bitstream cap un moment donné peut-être
ce soir déjà et demain avec des petites
ce rythme là est tournée on demain il y
aura quand même le title kiousis je
crois 22 heures ça commence à
embrouiller mercredi encore le tournoi
je dis je souffle jeudi ces femmes qui
stream fera une petite master class je
le dis je souffle ben oui c'est une
bonne interview rien à voir avec son
passage chez ruquier où tu sentais que
les chroniqueurs s'en ficher total avec
des questions banales wen ont elles été
plutôt basse et bien réussi je trouve
l'interview en tout cas j'ai trouvé ça
cool j'avais un petit peu peur parce
qu'après avoir autant stream ça pouvait
être un peu compliqué au niveau de la
concentration par rapport à maxime mais
pense que c'était plutôt intéressant
les trois échecs gavin à tort c'est tu
fais trois échecs qui gagne la partie
combien la master class de fab jeudi
elle sera à 20h30 en termes de tarifs
gratuite et antonymes 49
après si tu veux soutenir la chaîne et
du coup ça va la chaîne pitch trim pour
nous aider c'est cool mais en soi la
masterclass elle sera gratuite
après on va dire allez financés par
l'esa belle sera financé par les seuls
en fait ils ont ça comme ça c'est mieux
dire financés par les simples que
gratuite peut-être parce que du coup
c'est grâce au sable que l'on peut le
faire donc on va dire financés par les
sables c'est officiel à vitry va du coup
tu finances la master class de jeudi et
salua green kamkar mythe frog s'apprécie
donc on verra moins de monde qui jouera
aujourd'hui forcément là on est que 26
que trois échecs ça fait peur aux gens
mais ça permet de découvrir un jeu
j'aime bien vous faire découvrir des
jeux c'est intéressant peut-être va
devenir très très fort aux trois échecs
et on va on va on va en coller une
petite hausse heures botta dritta faut
que j'écrive à alexandra vu
qu'apparemment elle veut stream avec moi
un voilà c'était quand même l'objectif
caché de la bitstream cup 1 voilà faut
le savoir
et pour me faire un petit stream avec
alexandra je suis très heureux enfin je
dis à ma femme ouais je l'exprimé avec
alexandra pendant de 23h à 2h du matin
voilà n'avait paturel qui si toi aussi
tu veux la paix chaud non non non non
moi j'ai la femme la plus idéale du
monde
ma femme est extraordinaire pour rien au
monde je la changerait même pas
alexandra ce pour te dire
asus et trois échecs paquito barré en
échec deux échecs trois échecs et salua
nike killer 00 salut tonton bonjour
countryman 37
c'est la vente que j'aime moins perse
autre déséquilibre ira au centre c'est
top 3 de la montagne tu veux dire oui
bon on essaiera en faire un autre jour
le charretier produit trois échecs fait
gaffe ça lui frank zappa ça les
antonymes quelle marque de thé je peux
te conseiller tu crois quoi comme tu es
anthony moore n'en parlera ce soir vient
aux alentours de 20h15
après macron du coup on pour un petit
peu en discuter est ce que je vais faire
du crédit oui pourquoi pas entre eux
risquent d'échouer dans une des soeurs
botez non mais c'est pas trop mon style
en vrai vraiment sans déconner c'est pas
c'est pas trop mon style
j'en parlais une dette que tu sur le
coude en juillet a su s c'est maxime qui
est sur le coup
si tu me suis sur instagram je regarde
mes abonnements et tu tu comprendras
beaucoup mieux lipton et j'aime pas trop
coulant mais lipton c'est n'importe quoi
antonymes faut être sérieux là on lipton
c c'est comme si tu me dis non mais tu
peux apprendre linton je dirais même pas
du thé en fait ça fait ça fait très très
mal ça fait très très mal lipton
antonymes c'est comme si tu me dis tu me
recommande qu en termes de burgers et
que et que je te réponds mcdonald's si
tu vois prend achète du thé au palais
d'été mais je te ferai je ferais que je
fasse des conseils coiffage façon fassin
conseille t
dans la partie qu'on va être validés
slada mais il te parle de ça crie à l'
sa crise botez sefyu faut suivre faut
suivre le twitt du game 1 sefyu 30
ils vont expliquer
alors que toi va démarrer le lien je
vais leur mettre s'agisse bowden alors
maugrée on va essayer de mettre trois
échecs
j'ai peur soit beaucoup plus fort que
moi ils m'ont l'air de connaître la
théorie vous ne surtout pas couché au
toucher aux pions b as well as et
coutumes est un échec
ok là c'est une bonne nouvelle ce que je
vais mettre deux échecs au tir insurgé
me deux échecs il manque
il manque un échec et j'ai gagné en gros
on fait n'importe quelle menace déchets
qui fait très très mal et mon roi est
déjà bien blindé je pense que tu es si
c'était une grosse erreur
je vais pousser au centre le truc c'est
que si bien que le cavalier là je peux
peut-être prendre prendre 6 et 6 me
prend du fou y aura échec et sim prend
du plomb y aura échec
en gros je veux ouvrir les lignes
je pense qu'il doit bouger son cavale tu
attends b 8 puis on prend et et
reprendre du fou mais bon fallait faire
un carré des quatre menaces qui est
progressiste qui comprend un système à
cinq échecs
j'ai dit que j'étais nullissime mettez
un autre mot anglais font la une en a
oui en fait tu faire un genre de blagues
comme ça comme ça du coup je veux menace
est prise prises et damages sac
qui est dan 17 plutôt bien joué je vais
faire un 5 sur fion 30 cavaliers prend
et sur d'un cran d un jeu pranger cet
intermédiaire ok ils étaient cinq
je vais développer sur un échec de la
gloire mais dan f3 était aussi une
option pour menacer à sa gagner
peut-être même la f3 et là je fais kébé
5 en fait je voulais ce cavalier c'est
cet échec
et s'ils bougent le roi je fais camaïeu
6-3 d'échec
ça a gagné l'idée c'est que les
cavaliers comme tu peux pas à couvrir
les échecs et que j'ai menacé de partout
c'était imparable
les trois échecs sont sont tombés mais
c'était grosse erreur en dans
l'ouverture de sa part tutu doit jamais
laisser un échec t'arriver dessus quoi
je pousse 5 1 je prends quand même le
centre ok là c'est moi qui ai déconné je
vais prendre un échec ici parce que si
je fais des cinq chefs ou v5 j'aurais dû
faire au 6e paragraphe 6 du coup je vais
encaissé la pièce et je vais être quasi
perdre en direct ok je faire dams est il
des sections fou prend je veux faire
dame prend est comme ça quand il fait
cavalier prendre bougez vous là
je vais perdre comme mon adversaire 5
c'est une grosse erreur au début j'avais
oublié je suis très très mal qui est des
cinq vous prendre un grand fou prendre
wade 8
c'est peut-être que je peux faire de
mieux au moins je prends un seul échec
et je cache le roi que si je prends il
va me faire d'un f3 donc ok je prends un
échec mais je me chez cas je fasse gaffe
à bruno m'a déjà dit qu'il était mal
classé mais qui jouait mieux que son
classement ne le ne laisse transparaître
j'ai envie de me blinder avec fouet
cette histoire de ne plus me prendre des
chèques ici je vais faire un coup de
tourets fuite
ok ça c'est grosse erreur dans le france
est un échec
donc déjà je fais un échec et en plus je
gagne du matos il a pas vu la découverte
pourquoi tu voues papillon dessins que
ces faits dessin qui avait fugué et 5e
en effet un échec c'est c'est une barque
sont là on joue à une variante des
échecs c'est pas c'est pas des échecs
habituel mince on voit pas on va pas le
pouls de la colonne a désolé j'avais
oublié de remettre
- vous aviez dû me l'écrire et puis à et
puis j'ai oublié de remettre bien comme
il faut
désolé les gars voilà du coup je fais
deux échecs
j'avais à me trois échecs qui gagne et
je suis bête
j'aurais fait dames 3 il faisait pions
franches zf au hca troisième échec c'est
fini on est plus je jouais des cinq ici
pour le moment
vous pouvez 4 way mais bon juge et
recadrer au moment où il y avait ça et
du coup je me suis déconcentré
faux et 6 l'idée c'est que je veux pas
laisser faire 3-2 pour faire pousser
quatre échecs je faire c'est si facile
peut pas mais tant il peut pas mettre en
échec
non c'est cool parce que je suis un
échec du mat quoi
jega gagne depuis quatre mois mais fou
gk3 ces deux noms à elle avait peut-être
paroisse et de à l'époque j'étais plus
fort que moi j'ai du mal
l'alliance et 6 je vais faire 3,8
ok là je pense ça gagne ouest et 2g faut
prendre qu'à 3 2 les fous b53 20 g fou
b4 ouverture hyper importante ouais mais
moi j'ai raté mon ouverture la retient
mefou g4 devait gagner
moi aussi j'ai raté mon ouverture on
joue contre mon gré donc y sont que 6
soit important et il sent que ça se soit
fort
ok je vais prendre un petit relief 6
et du coup je vais prendre lui
mais j'ai pas des cinq ce que fout les
cinq échecs est un problème je vais de
repartir avec le cavalier je pense pas
que damages 4 pour donner la dame soit
worth
je pense que vous prend à f2 est
intéressant
ok je vais rockets
par contre qu'il sait si ce qui est des
cats est intéressant parce que sur
quatre ans j'aurais d'un match 4 très
clairement ce cavalier ne peut pas
bouger
qui prend des quatre fous prend des
quatre maintenant quelques bruits québec
ajmq français de suivi d'un match 4 et
là tu voulais faire tirer les f-5
fu g5 et prend des 4 prend des huit qui
prend le deux reprises deux prises dès 8
heures avec un n 3 qui ont pour pour la
pièce
quelle paire d'arrières 6
je sais pas comment évoluer sa évaluer
cette position
qui prend le troisième contrat qui prend
des trois pions prend des 3 quelle idée
si ce fut pour h7
je prends des trois maîtres madame
angers 6 1 il prend comme ça et faire b
5 alors prendre c'est suicidaire jet
tours b 8
je veux faire flamber 7
gkd farc étaient six
ce que sur roy ces deux jeux b4 il joue
assez bien faire b4 quand même
la grosse question et c'est ce qui bouge
le cavalier d'arpin f1 et worth ou pas
j'ai peur que non
ok que je peux faire c'est 5 et 6 prend
je fais retour c'est 8
ok je fais retour si tu as tout reprend
et d'un prend b2 ils se cachent encore
jamais le fou en d5
maintenant s'ils bougent le cavaly gdam
praf tom prenait fin et froid de maths
et maintenant qui est b5 inscrit ses
trois échecs
qu'ai-je l'arsel quand même hein je
crois que je harcèle bien et sur oib
deux tours prend ses 5
je récupère ma pièce et je garde le jeu
je crois je suis en train de lui faire
mal comme on préférerait mais je mets un
échec subi fac ci fait 2,5 dame prenait
fin je rappelle on joue aux 3 et chacun
il a abandonné
je pense j'ai fait une bonne game là tu
penses j'ai vraiment bien joué sept
parties tuent pas ce que vous en pensez
mais je pense était une bonne game en
quart ça c'est pas con c'est pas content
du tout
2627 cette icône et un peu de théorie ça
te fait refouler 517 je veux pas prendre
des chèques évidemment ce qu'ils me
disent des fonds davantage le jeu fait
je suis prêt à prendre juste un échec
pour une pièce éventuellement mais
jamais plus qu'elle à ce que je veux
faire c'est dévié son pion faire pousser
5 était d'avoir des fous prend est sûre
qu'ils avalaient prend pions prend ou c5
je pense pas que d'un prend 17 soit joie
que je fais dame prend pour un échec une
dame s'est trop chère dame g4
madame recettes
ayvaz fait refouler 5
donc elle faire part à d'autres ça a dû
faire plonger et cinq sur foot rangée 5
je fais retour g8
ce qui peut être intéressant
un bref sur vous prévenez yves leroy h1
tout le temps où l'aca c'est hyper
dangereux
ferme 7e cadran rock mais j'ai une
poubelle
c'est une poubelle mais ici ça va je
pensais foot rangée 5 tours g8 d'arâches
4 ça me fait un peu peur très
honnêtement mais bon il a plus qu'une
minute c'est tactique que je serais
plutôt mettre cette tour du cou
c'est chaud c'est bien bien tactique
comme jeu c'est hyper compliqué kg le
droit qui est proprement leader du
tournoi
quels faits tour d'air je vais jouer à 6
pour lui faire prendre une décision avec
son fouet peut-être lors des cavaliers
prend 1,5 à relief trois fous prend f2
genre de choses ok du coup je prends là
ah si j'ai tout reprend conception
prouver 5 à la prime si tu vas retour
france et 7
qui est très bien joué j'ai oublié ça
c'était pas un coût des chèques normale
et du coup j'ai oublié le cas tu force
et ça j'ai vu
ça comme ça non il ya foule est ici si
si non food et 6 ok ça va et merde et ça
va encore
il faut que je bloque la colonne est
vrai que j'échange les tours ok si j'ai
changé des tours je suis très très bien
je suis très très bien parce qu'en fait
parce qu'en fait il a du mal à mettre
des échecs quoi
je sens qu'il ya des bagues avec la
pendule où il ya un rajout de temps à
ses trois plus 2
ok fox et qui peut pas vraiment faire
grand chose vous jamais que je passe sur
noir en fait un échec et trois échecs
la grosse défense un rsi soit mais je
voulais prendre aucun risque
je fais une grosse défense là je suis
2803 échec qui peut s'asseoir à ma table
2803 échec c'est choquant
ok je vais vite rockets
j'avais rauque et puis on verra plus
tard marrant ce jeu où pareille ce qui
vous plaît dans le tchat
ok ça c'est pas un échec qui me posent
trop souci quand même jouable si je peux
prendre du cavalier une pièce pour un
échec ça me paraît toujours cher mais
bon
j'espère qu'ici sur le système de l'ong
qui me fait mettre le pion 5
manquer je commence je développe mes
pièces ça apporte pas sérieux c'est
juste amusé bas qu'est ce que tu fais ma
direct bah tu gagnes mais fou proche
celle qui prend à cette cavale et h5
c'est intéressant
je pensais qu'ils feraient ça du coup je
vais là enfermé faire ça
je prends une fois
et je veux venir ici mais c'est
peut-être pas mal hein je me barre avec
laurent h 8 au manger vite tous les fous
prend h7 et les tours prend g7 mais
maintenant je vais essayer de mettre la
pression sur son roi à lui
le long de la colonne eux surtout je
mets la pression autant ok je vais
prendre une fois le cavale prendre une
fois ici
je vais reprendre chaque food et 6
j'espère qu'avec 4 je peux faire damas
cinq échecs par et pénible parce que sur
food et de dame prend des deux il est
fini je vais pouvoir placer mon premier
échec
ok il met échec mais je compterai chèque
donc ça compte pas vraiment deux échecs
déloyale troisième qui arrive au
prochain les trois échecs qui tombe
bouby poupe dangereux pipe ou pas on est
piégé refaire le c3 qu'en effet tout à
l'heure ça m'a eu l'air intéressant
pour essayer de jouer des quatre cgfr b5
sur logic est ok au moins je me
tranquillise je mette la tour à faire
des 4,5 j'aime bien mais qu'est ce que
je peux prendre
je vais prendre ici ok je fais un échec
quand même je prends ici
khiêm a donné un échec mais il
s'activait je mettre le feu 3 parce que
je veux couvrir cette diagonale et 10,2
un échec de plus mais il a la paire de
fou il ya de bien jouer ça va être plus
facile dans cette position donnée les
échecs avec les fous mais bon
ok ça j'avais pensé prendre et faire
food et 4
c'est compliqué de gérer et les échecs
et
devant h1 cependant
sur ces cinq chefs ou 3 et ça j'ai vu
mais je reviens avec le cavalier part
expliqué prends je suis fou prend ce pas
si grave c'est que j'ai besoin de rester
je suis à 0 échec
maintenant je vais f3 au prochain chassé
le cavalier mon rang h1 il super bien et
je prends un des six
sur ce je voulais faire france et 5
france et cinq épreuves de la finale
elle est dure évalué
je pense qu'elle est gagnante quand même
sur kg 3g fg
à tours 6 j'avais pas vu ce très bien
joué ça parce que sur foot roi qui prend
f2 suis dans la merde sur foot - f2 tour
pointent en pointe en coin ça fait trois
échecs
aïe aïe aïe du coup je dois rendre la
caboche et sans avez vu tout à l'heure
c'était très dur à défendre il a mieux
joué que moi
c'est foutu j'ai plus de temps plus
sarrès est fini des rejouer encore ouais
t'es le seul coup je me suis planté
avait bien joué je veux avoir une bonne
position
raté raté les trois échecs se réveille
c'est dur comme je rejoue vise 100
losail v5 avec mon vélo je vous que les
meilleurs tout le temps assidu ressort à
un look meilleurs que ceux des autres
alors m sicilienne va faire ses 3
alors comment rejoindre le tournoi
paraît ici c'est dur comme jeu hyper dur
hyper compliqué ce jeu marrant mais
compliqué me sens qui a l'air d'avoir
l'habitude industrie marthaler je re
stream après macron je vais essayer d un
peu dormir après je suis un peu dans le
dur
je me rends h à voir un peu ce qu'il
fait
jarvis est bien couvert
méfiera les horaires est fort église et
déjà j'ai pu à calar c'est mercredi
mais c'est pas sûr que je fasse tout les
stream aussi je sais pas j'ai pas quel
point vous aurez avoir respecté
ah je gêne à j'ai une panne cérébrale
j'essayais d'aller avec la dame là bas
mais le problème c'est qu'il est un pion
de trop dans son roi jean raison que les
fous sont en plus fort que les cavaliers
à ce jeu j'ai 33 ans franchit pas
pendant macron je pourrais strié l'unc
ont tué hier c'est de jouer vite
je sais juste que là je suis déconcentré
je tiens pas spécialement à me refaire
des formes concentraient donc on va
jouer vite pendant j'ai pas pris des
chèques donc ça va ouah ça me paraît fou
ça ah oui mais trois échecs comme ça
ouais c'est bien joué
j'aurais dû calculer belle tactique
ouais j'ai un peu décroché la wii c'est
un quine à tort
j'ai un peu décroché même beaucoup
d'amis tu peux pas donner comme ça hein
ça les chèques pour une dame m'a laissé
fesf à une petite partie de repos mais
enfin tombé sur un joueur moins fort ça
me parait dû mettre les trois échecs à
l'essai cheveux à une carreaux can't
le jeu est compliqué vraiment on a quand
même 75 à avoir alors tenté de trois
échecs vraiment rien en fait il ya ouais
c'est un jeu spécial 1 c'est une
variante des échecs te suffit de faire
croire des chèques pour gagner
vous verrez la paire de fou et j'ai
l'impression aussi a par deux fois à
l'air pas mal
la paire de fois la race et max ouais
tfg le droit qui est pas mal il est 4e
il a dit sûr qu'il fait bien défoncé
mais il a gagné beaucoup de parties il a
le droit bordel hammami si je vais en
perdre un fou
half life 3 1 je réponds un message je
vais rockets ça c'est pareil j'ai ramené
un pion vers droit
à voir ce que ça donne
j'ai trois mètres le quai en 17 ans
d'attenté qui avait capté quand même six
ans sur ce live
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'on soit
autant je pensais qu'on serait dans les
200 300 salut macarons me retire parce
que là on vous n'accrochez pas trop pour
les variantes mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
assez nombreux oui c'est bien blindé les
cases noires du coup moi je vais faire
une attaque à l'ancienne
c'est de prendre part qu elle sait
peut-être que je vois échec normal jouer
la case de 4 et tout le tralala
le roi de la colline de huit semaines le
roi sans tête devant ce fut un roi de la
colline salut doomed aléria
sept ou huit c'est une bouffée un pion
jouer vite et bien c'est ce qu'on veut
kirby show le plus bas je peux pas
descendre évincé de la chance sa
remontée sur deux de ne plus régressé
c'est cool pour participer je remets
lien à l'essai de la gagne et donc
repartir repartir de l'avant
protéger mon pions
pas filer des pions en main faire ça
comme ça mais s'y prend pour preuve
cette je suis mal à lâcher en train de
primes c'est que je pense trop échec
normes paris j'ai reperdu tourage 5 et
11.7 part mais je suis incapable de voir
ces trucs là en fait ouais c'est trop
dur pour moi c'est trop dur pour moi un
match gagne aussi ouais ouais j'ai
oublié ce truc là maintenant je suis
découragé la plus en vue ces problèmes
des variantes je souffre tellement avec
les variantes en fait je fais quatre
parties j'en ai déjà marre cette roi de
la colline ce sera mieux tu peux plus
faire des vraies parties d'échecs de
base
être obligé de hadj est d'être concentré
un minimum en fait si je me concentre si
je trahis par dans fait mon cerveau ils
voient que des trucs normaux jouer aux
échecs normaux bêtement les idées les
combinaisons qui me viennent à l'esprit
sont juste des combinaisons normal le
reste ne vient pas à l'esprit place d'un
lieu d'un autre côté tant mieux
je prends trois essais se joue aux
échecs norway non mais en fait le truc
c'est que tant que j'étais concentré il
n'avait pas le coup de pompe ça va en
fait
mais dès que je commence à être en des
curiaces être en pilote automatique en
fait je vois une vraie partie d'échecs
ça c'est un vrai problème
cette 3ème de à tout moment est bon pour
éviter de prendre un congé trois mâles
en fait c'est sur le truc où je
considère qu'il vaut mieux avoir les
pièces que les échecs
je sais pas si ma théorie est exact
question assez sage parquet prend ses
huit il faut prend à 6 quand même
ce qui serait quand même très cool bref
faut pas lâcher la concentration parce
que ouais t'as pas de pain comme joue
pas assez à ce jeu là t'as pas d'auto
pilote en fait les réflexes des chèques
reviennent et ses marais moi j'ai quand
même très envie d'aller chercher cette
tour qui est française le roi g1 cavalli
prend un statut faire tout reprend h 7
passes et sa barbarian quand les
réflexes des chèques reviennent c'est
fini c'est extrêmement dangereux
je farfouille 4 faire une focale sur le
cavalier
je vais rater encore un pion
je vais revenir avec mon cavale vers f4
comme ça je me lancerai prendre la main
ça là ça va je suis en contrôle
on va mettre encore un échec pour gagner
moi 2 mais j'en ai à tout moment ici ça
je vais venir à la
je vais faire ça et ça
comme ça je la slaj menace là il peut
pas empêcher
c'est le troisième kg 5 je n'ai pas trop
non rejoue bruno départ elle joue un
match en d4
petit rappel des règles moyens faire
trois échecs à gagner voilà tout le
reste est identique exactement tout le
reste est naturel ou wii naturel je ne
plaçait des cinq qui étaient possibles
j'ai pas été très intelligent
les réflexes des chèques normaux ses
rangs de la merde
un peu d espace là bas on sait jamais
deux tracés bien joué ça et je prends
une fois là
bon je les rejette pas mal voilà ça va
ça me faire dame de plus d'un pièce de
plus et j'ai les échecs qui arrive donc
ça gagnait ça me permet de remonter un
petit peu l asphyxie minutes 50
ouvertures hippopotames ont bien
fonctionné mais le truc c'est qu'après
tu restes h avec le truc c'est qu'ils
popo tam
l'inconvénient c'est que tu crées pas de
menaces après c'est toujours pareil hein
toujours pareil sachez qu'il ne respecte
pas qui veut mettre d échec d'entrée par
une galère audry bref à tekken troisième
du tournoi tu es devant moi barbarian
guerrière pas tant que ça barba ni les
troisièmes ils galèrent c'est ouf ça bon
ça le truc c'est que je prends du
cavalier du queen mais pas d'échec pas
d'échec c'est un chèque pas d'échec
attention dans magique à djeddah me
prend
ben c'est beaucoup il est 4e cape j'ai
le droit qui est bien barbare ni les
deuxièmes du tournoi
il galère le gay va être gagné le
tournoi en galérant quoi oui la dame
le staff y ait qu on va aller s'amuser
mais un échec ça shake avoir du mal à en
mettre deux autres t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer
genre est un échec par tous deux échecs
et trois échecs bien se passer ne
t'inquiète pas malheureusement ça ne
remonte pas trop ça a appris qu'il
fallait mieux avoir un stylo dans ce
tournoi c'est vrai que tu peux gagner
beaucoup plus vite contre les joueurs
supposés moins fort
on n'a pas eu d'adversaire c'est pas
faux mais je vais compliqué on a on a
les habitués du jeu un pou pi poupe
maugréer mr louis savoie qu'il en a un
peu joué
il regarde un peu connaître mais
barbarian qui va quand même gagné le
tournera vite reste plus que trois
minutes vrai que c'est que j'aime et mg
est elle-même maugrée tu ne devais pas
dicter un maugrée différents en tout cas
il s'en sort bien ce mot gré n'était pas
un mot clé différents
le cemagref way sur le tchat je m'en
sors plus avec les mots greffe au lei
s'est il y en a trop en fait
ces mauvaises canard suit la bicici
schaaf
c'est vrai de canard
je m'en sors pas entre savoir lesquels
ont déjà joué jamais joué j'ai eu de
1800 m'ont quand même mais bon je tombe
à 23 40 sûrement très bien jouer sa
chanson qui rockent moins que moi les
gens mais à trop de mots gré en fait
être marrant ce jeu quand même
dégagez bloquer son four je vais
chercher les échecs maintenant j'ai
quand même ma pièce de plus ces biens
immobilisés rendent une fois la journée
une tour
bref 6 j'arrive tour en attaque ça je
prends du cavale ce que vous faites
c'est fou pranger dame prend qui est
cool
là je commence à être bien dans cette
partie non parce que j'ai le fou aussi
qui vient en attaque mais je prends la
route ranger deux tours deux échecs
je vais par an le temps de la fir
il va tomber pas y arriver il reste plus
que cinq secondes dans le tournoi mais
je pense que des gagnants
eq aviez le droit qui finit deuxième
quand même bordel j'ai le droit
bon bah c'était cool ça ça vous a plu ou
pas de change un petit peu on pourra se
faire un roi de la colline à 14e stade
cheikh bien joué
tu sais pas si ça vous plaît de faire
des petites des petites variantes comme
ça de temps à autre
bon bah du coup je vous remercie à tous
d'avoir suivi et je vous dis à bientôt
les amis à ce soir ciao à tous